نحاول أن
نوضح لروسيا الآن أنه إذا دخلوا
فلن يكون الأمر سهلاً ،
فأنا هنا منذ أكثر من عامين ونصف
وقد رأيت القوات الأوكرانية
الوطنية  حراسة
حرس الحدود الأوكرانيين حيث يعملون ،
لقد ذهبت في جميع أنحاء البلاد ويمكنني
أن أخبرك أن الأوكرانيين سيقاتلون
الأوكرانيين يحبون بلدهم ،
فهم وطنيون سيقفون
وسيقاتلون ولن يكون لدى الروس أي
وقت سهل من
الناحية الواقعية.  هل تعتقد أن
فلاديمير بوتين سوف يتم تأجيله بسبب
بعض العقوبات إذا رأى نفسه على
أنه الزعيم الروسي الذي استعاد
أوكرانيا ربما في المستقبل
يعيد احتضان
روسيا البيضاء ، لقد استعاد بالفعل شبه جزيرة القرم التي سيرغب في
النزول إليها  التاريخ كرجل
أعاد توسيع الأراضي الروسية يمكنه أن
يتجاهل بعض العقوبات بالتأكيد
، فإن العقوبات التي نتحدث
عنها شديدة للغاية وسيكون لها
ثمن مالي باهظ للغاية على اقتصاد روسيا ولكن
هناك أشياء أخرى مثل  حسنًا ، أولاً وقبل
كل شيء ،
ستكون روسيا منبوذة دوليًا
بصراحة ، وإذا كان هذا هو المكان الذي يريدون
الذهاب إليه ،
فلا أعتقد أنه مكان لطيف
للغاية ، وفي النهاية إذا كان مكانك
في التاريخ يجعلك
أنت وبلدك منبوذًا عالميًا  منبوذ
لا أعتقد أن هذا بالضرورة إرث
تريد تركه